Bye-bye, Batfleck.
This is the dawning of the age of Battinson.
After much speculation about who would replace
Ben Affleck as Bruce Wayne in director Matt
Reeves' The Batman, we finally know who the
lucky actor is: Robert Pattinson.
Sources close to Variety have noted that Pattinson,
who broke into the mainstream with the Twilight
franchise and has since gone on to make a
major name for himself in the drama genre
and with arthouse films, is in final negotiations
with studio Warner Bros. to top-line the feature
as the titular DC Comics hero.
The ink on the contract hasn't dried just
yet, but the deal is expected to close soon.
"It's hard to explain, but I need you to be
open-minded.
Can you do that?"
Warner Bros. declined to comment on the news,
but it looks like Pattinson will take flight
to become the Caped Crusader before too long,
as The Batman is slated to start pre-production
sometime this summer and could go in front
of cameras either late this year or early
next.
For many who've kept their fingers on the
pulse of all things related to The Batman,
learning that Pattinson is about to rise as
the new Bruce Wayne and assume the mantle
from Affleck, who dropped out of The Batman
as its director and its star, comes as little
surprise.
Rumors have been swirling for months now,
and at one point gained so much traction that
artists began crafting digital works envisioning
what the English actor would look like in
the Batsuit and dressed up in black-tie attire
as the billionaire Bruce Wayne.
Other actors, including Armie Hammer, Logan
Lerman, Jack O'Connell, Ansel Elgort, Dylan
O'Brien, Aaron Taylor-Johnson, Noah Centineo,
Richard Madden, and Kit Harington, were reported
contenders for the leading role in The Batman,
but it's clear that Pattinson was the favorite.
Warner Bros. and Reeves evidently love Pattinson
so much that they've tapped him before the
final version of the film's script is even
complete.
It's true: Right now, Reeves is still polishing
the story before locking it in, but he apparently
couldn't wait to secure Pattinson before then.
Reeves was said to be scouting for an actor
15 to 20 years younger than Affleck, who's
in his mid-40s.
Pattinson fits that age range nicely.
According to Variety, Warner Bros. is giving
Reeves as much time as needed to make The
Batman as perfect as possible, starting with
the script and the cast.
The studio reportedly hopes that this version
of the famed DC vigilante makes up for how
the character was depicted in Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice and Justice League.
Reeves previously described his take on the
iconic superhero as an "almost-noir driven,
detective version of Batman," and the film
as a whole as being influenced by the works
of Alfred Hitchcock.
Reeves told The Hollywood Reporter in June
of 2017,
"What I try to do [...] is use the camera
and use the storytelling so that you become
that character, and you emphasize with that
point of view.
There's a chance to do [a version of Batman]
that is point-of-view driven in a very, very
powerful way, that will hopefully connect
you to what's going on inside of his head
and inside of his heart."
To many, Pattinson is still and will always
be Edward Cullen from the Twilight saga.
"This is who I am."
But the actor has done some genuinely fantastic
work in the time after the five-movie fantasy-romance
franchise wrapped in 2012.
Pattinson went from glittering in the Washington
state sun as the brooding vampire, to dazzling
in films like The Lost City of Z, Good Time,
and High Life.
Pattinson is set to appear in The Lighthouse,
The King, and Waiting for the Barbarians in
2019 alone.
The Batman is a project unlike anything Pattinson
has done in his career thus far, and it gives
the actor, whose biggest film role will likely
always precede him, a chance to show millions
of people who haven't kept up with his post-Twilight
work that he's more than just the vampire
guy.
Pattinson does have a lot to live up to, since
many actors have played Batman before him,
but the potent combination of his sharpened
acting chops, his status as a sort-of-underdog,
and the positive response his casting in The
Batman has already received hints that he'll
more than live up to expectations.
"What are you?"
"I'm Batman."
The Batman hits theaters on June 25th, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the DCEU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.